Sunday night Elvis star Austin Butler
made his first public appearance since
Lisa Marie's passing at the Critics
Choice Awards Brendan Frazier Austin
lost the best actor award to the whale
star Brendan Fraser who delivered one of
the most emotional speeches of the night
get to your feet and go to the light
good things will happen the evening also
marked an epic reunion more than 30
years in the making the presence will be
a valuable asset to our organization
Brendan gave a big hug to his 1992
Encino Man co-star kiwi Kwan he won the
best supporting actor award for
everything everywhere all at once it's
good to see him again I love you man
when we saw each other for the first
time after 30 years he put his hand on
my shoulder and he said this he was
still here
was still here I would never forget
those three words later key joined his
co-stars on stage as they took home the
night's Top Honor best picture one cast
made missing Jamie Lee Curtis who was
home sick with covet but facetimed to
The Press Room that's everybody here
oh God she's crying
leading up to the award Jamie Lee posed
in this t-shirt of her viral reaction to
Michelle Yo's Golden Globes win she's a
team t-shirt now so Kate Blanchette
Jamie Lee's good friend Kate Blanchette
beat Michelle in the best actress
category on stage the tar star called
for an end to how award show winners are
picked stop the televised horse race of
it all I think there's a different way
of of celebrating uh performances
Chelsea Handler hosted the show and took
aim at Prince Harry's Memoir spare
dollar became the third highest viewed
Show on Netflix with a combined watch
time of 1 billion hours which apparently
is the same amount of time we're gonna
have to listen to Prince Harry talk
about his frostbitt
but the night's winners provided some
much needed inspiration it's not over
till it's over it's it's not over till
you're dead
thank you Mommy and Daddy because this
one's for you
people don't have to like you
people don't have to love you they don't
even have to respect you
but when you look in the mirror
you better love what you see
to everybody who doubted this black
woman and told me what I couldn't do I
looked lovely and humbly sad in your
face
dahmerstar Nissi Nash bets proved her
critics wrong with her win for best
supporting actress in a limited series
backstage she responded to the series
backlash Now understand it when you
think about the Dahmer's victims we
didn't know who they were before this
series the final season of Better Call
Saul took home three trophies Bob
Odenkirk thanked his co-star Ray seahorn
who helped save his life during his
onset heart attack in 2021. she was the
one who had to hold a dead man's head up
Ray and I did this together the Dropout
Amanda seifred was shocked after the
Dropout won best limited series E.T was
with her on the red carpet where she
revealed new secrets about what kept her
away from the Golden Globes last week
you're literally making a musical about
Thelma and Louise with Evan Rachel Wood
the creators are working diligently to
bring something
Beyond Comprehension to life onto the
stage and this leather jacket she rocked
on stage it was covering a rip in her
gorgeous gold dress it's really old it's
archival Dior just trying to keep it on
another big winner Angela Bassett taking
home best supporting actress with the
best supporting husband Courtney B Vance
by her side are going to be recording
and capturing everything like you do at
the globe no I'm gonna let that go
Courtney bronwin and Slater I love you
you know what he was in that audience
with this he couldn't help himself he
could not help himself
ungovernable that is he what is it like
having your number one cheerleader oh
it's wonderful we all need one Courtney
put his phone away to fluff Angela's
velvet Christian siriano gown on the
carpet also in Black Christina Applegate
rocking a suit and matching Kane at her
first award show since her Ms diagnosis
for plus one eleven-year-old daughter
Sadie also in a pant suit Christina lost
to Jean Smart for hacks but still had a
blast posing alongside Julia Roberts and
showing off her Jen and Judy Manny a nod
to dead to me I wasn't mean to share
this night with Christina we'll be here
to comfort each other as we always do
I'm proud of what she's accomplished the
top gun Maverick crew swapped their
uniforms for some sweet tuxes Anya
Taylor joy and Sarah Hyland proved to be
the night's cutest besties and Kerry
Washington stunned in a sequined Giorgio
Armani Prive gown and selected by her
kids I decided to do Glam at my parents
house the kids the parents the Glam
Squad it was fun
Aubry Plaza was fire in her custom Louis
Vuitton dress with an ombre neckline the
White Lotus star covered up backstage
with 13-time SNL host John Goodman maybe
getting tips for her gig this weekend
are you excited about SNL oh yes I am
John was actually a last-minute invite
brought in to honor The Big Lebowski
co-star Jeff Bridges with the Lifetime
Achievement Award after original
presenter Michelle Pfeiffer tested
positive for kovit they got your Big
Lebowski co-star to present to you here
Walter let's go bold
are we getting that sequel I don't know
you gotta talk to the brothers about it
I kind of doubt it the big honor also
made Jeff reflective and grateful I was
sick for two years with cancer and covet
my family Sue and my daughters talk
about their support during that time you
know I didn't think I was gonna make it
at all we're gonna let alone going back
to work Janelle Monae picked up
tonight's other special honor the see
her Award presented by her Glass Onion
co-star Kate Hudson what's the magic of
Janelle Monae I think just her
authenticity and her expression of self
it's personal because I am non-binary
I am queer and my identity influences my
decisions and my work thank you
[Music]